vous en prie il faut que vous m'aidiez
je peux plus rester si je voudrais un
autre entente spécifique avec mes
enfants pour que déraper leur peau nous
n'avons aucune possibilité d'hébergement
actuelle aucun centre d'hébergement pour
les femmes battues
telle était la réalité en france en 1976
à l'époque les violences conjugales sont
encore tabou et les femmes qui osent
briser le silence sont rares je voulais
crier encore au secours et il m'a mis le
point dans la bouche
et puis il m'a maintenu en noyer pour
que les moyens de les mentons pas crier
pour écouter et accompagner ces femmes
une poignée de féministes se regroupent
l'association sos femmes battues milite
alors pour une meilleure prise en charge
des victimes
en 1975 elle ouvre une permanence
téléphonique d'urgence
une première en france un nouveau les
aider à s'aider elle-même cdsn
possibilité pour qu'elle puisse en
sortir
mais plus que l'aide morale médicales et
juridiques à leur accorde déjà ses
militantes réclame un refuge pour
protéger les femmes battues et leurs
enfants
l'obtention de ce refuge est urgente et
nécessaire à plusieurs titres
d'une part parce que les femmes qui se
retrouvent dans la rue ne sachant pas où
aller finit souvent par retourner chez
lui marie et nous rappellent plusieurs
mois après d'autre part il est tout à
fait indispensable de rompre le cycle de
la violence qui se fait à l'intérieur
des foyers pour se faire entendre et
obtenir des subventions de l'état
l'association multiplie les actions en
1976 ses membres occupent un château en
région parisienne un lieu promis par la
secrétaire d'état chargée de la
condition féminine
on a beaucoup dit que veut la mesure où
nous avait donné à locale l'algérie nous
l'a dit elle même et puis on l'attend
toujours
il ya urgence il il ya urgence et il ya
155 qu'il faut loger
après plusieurs années de combat le
premier refuge pour femmes battues ouvre
enfin ses portes en 1978 pas dans un
château mais dans un local plus modestes
à clichy au nord de paris
expérience pilote ce foyer spécifique
veut être également une protection pour
les enfants
ils ont vécu trop tôt des rapports de
violence et pourraient être tentés de
les reproduire le refuge compte une
trentaine de lits on y reste environ six
semaines après une remise en question de
leur vie premier objectif pour ces
femmes obtenir l'autonomie par le
travail aujourd'hui 41 ans après
l'ouverture de ce centre
près de 5000 places d'hébergement
d'urgence sont disponibles en france
pour les victimes de violences
conjugales
[Musique]